The doctor at my IV center, so this person is doing IV vitamin C.
Keeps pushing me to do IV glutathione.
I know that you say no to this.
Why don't they understand its connection with cancer?
Well, I don't know what they're thinking.
I can only guess what they're thinking.
So most like that your pets or IV doctors, you know, clinicians that don't that treat cancer.
Maybe like this person, maybe he sees he or she sees a lot of people that have a diagnosis of cancer.
But that's all they do is interview this therapy.
So what do what can you get from you know to in the United States?
What can you get to use?
Well, you could use, you know, a combination of nutrition, which is common for some people to do, which I don't recommend because it's all synthetic.
You could do IV vitamin C, which is the most common thing that's administered.
You could do IV curcumin.
That's a not uncommon thing to be administered or you could do IV glutathione.
There's not a whole lot of other things that you can do.
You can't get B-17 IV in the United States.
So there's not a whole lot of other things that you can do intravenously.
So they're trying to sell packages, really.
And glutathione is another thing that they're selling.
I'm not saying that he's pushy here.
She is pushing it just because he can sell something to you.
I don't know his motivation.
But for someone to make recommendations to a cancer patient that doesn't understand cancer.
Yeah, I struggle with that, especially when you have said no, my doctor who I'm working with with cancer says no to glutathione.
Certainly, you could share with them some of my articles, some of my videos if they would be willing and open to look at that.
But the other thing probably where they're coming from is in their mind, you know, they went to school and said they went to an antropathic school or car practice school or medical school or something like that.
They learned that glutathione is good to help prevent cancer because glutathione is your main intercellular antioxidant.
So any oxidative stress within the cell is is squelched by glutathione catalysts and superoxide discreetase, but mainly glutathione.
So and it is intracellular oxidative stress that can cause cancer, so glutathione can help prevent cancer.
And that's all they remember from that class or from their studies.
They're not looking at how do you treat cancer?
How would you take care of a cancer patient differently than how would you prevent cancer?
Somebody already has a diagnosis of cancer.
You don't do glutathione because you could actually be helping a cancer cell stay alive.
And I've gone through that at nausea with you here, so I don't want to go over that again.
Yeah, lots of videos of that.
But those are the videos you could share with this practitioner because they don't know.
And this isn't like an alternative idea.
This isn't my idea.
This is well researched and well documented idea.
So they're not looking at the research on that and I'm not faulty enough on that, but maybe just give them that information.